Speaker 1: So Joe Biden is taking a very different
approach to foreign policy than the former
President Donald Trump talk, and we sort of have
like one of our first big foreign policy conflicts
to talk about. There's been a little bit of Joe
Biden talking about and around China policy and
tariffs and the like. But now it's Putin, and now
it's Russia, and things are very quickly getting
interesting. And unfortunately, any time I touch
this issue, I have to give some disclaimers which
I'm going to give in a moment. But the question
is what's going on? Well, what's going on is that
Speaker 2: during a video
Speaker 1: call with Russian President
Vladimir Putin yesterday, Joe Biden issued a
warning and the warning said in very simple terms,
is do not invade Ukraine or we are going to
hit you with very strong economic sanctions,
economic sanctions, and this is one of the first
Speaker 2: really
Speaker 1: major foreign policy events of its kind
with Joe Biden. Donald Trump made a really big
show. Out of bragging about how he would deal
with adversarial foreign leaders with Putin,
it was mostly kid gloves with Kim Jong UN. It was
falling for the obvious, meaningless platitudes
and promises that we've gotten from every
North Korean leader recently and thinking he
accomplished something. And, you know, we can look
at the full list of those relationships. Well,
for Joe Biden, it seems as though it's going to
go a little bit differently now. The context here,
if you've not been following it, is that U.S.
intelligence has determined that Russia has massed
what they believe to be 70000 troops near the
border with Ukraine and appears to be making
preparations for an invasion maybe as soon
as early in 2022. Now appears to be making
preparations is not just technically accurate.
It actually may be the entire point, which is to
gauge what the reaction is going to be
Speaker 2: of other major powers.
Speaker 1: But we're going to get to
that. Ukrainian officials are saying
Russia sending tanks, they're sending snipers,
they're trying to provoke returned fire
to then justify a full invasion. That's
the position of Ukrainian authorities.
Now I need to make my disclaimers.
Speaker 2: I know that for 90 percent
Speaker 1: of my audience, I don't have to
say this. I have to say it for 10 percent of
my audience, but if I don't, my inbox
becomes a hellscape. I am telling you
what Joe Biden is saying to Vladimir Putin.
I am not suggesting a war with Russia.
I am not cheerleading war with Russia.
Speaker 2: I don't want
war with Russia. Do not email
Speaker 1: me saying, David,
why are you such a neocon imperialist that you
want war with Russia? Trump wanted to get along.
Why? Why? Why? David, I'm not saying that.
Please don't email me that. Now in the call,
the belief is that Biden said, If you invade
Ukraine, we're going to hurt your economy.
Speaker 2: Putin was
Speaker 1: expected to ask for a guarantee from
Speaker 2: Joe Biden that the
Speaker 1: NATO military alliance
will never involve Ukraine. Ukraine wants
membership in that shared defense alliance.
Speaker 2: Putin doesn't want that now in
Speaker 1: advance of the call. White House
Press Secretary Jen Psaki put
out a statement where she said,
Speaker 2: quote, We've consulted
Speaker 1: significantly with our allies and
Speaker 2: believe we have a
Speaker 1: path forward that would
impose significant and severe harm on the
Speaker 2: Russian economy. You can call
Speaker 1: that a threat. You can call that a
fact, you can call that preparation. You can
call it whatever you want to call
it. That was Jen Psaki on Monday.
Speaker 2: So listen,
Speaker 1: this is not going to go
the way it went under Trump. This is going to be
different. Biden is not going to fly to Finland,
meet with Putin, do a press conference where he
Speaker 2: says, I don't know.
Speaker 1: I asked Putin if they hacked
us, and Putin denied it very strongly.
Speaker 2: OK.
Speaker 1: I don't know,
Putin said. His troops aren't really massing
at the border. They're just passing by on a
sightseeing tour. OK? That one I made up. The
first one happened under Trump. That last one
Speaker 2: I made up. That's not going to
Speaker 1: be the way it is under Joe Biden.
Speaker 2: This doesn't mean
Speaker 1: we want war
Speaker 2: with Russia. This doesn't mean we want
Speaker 1: Biden starting to drone
Speaker 2: Russia boots on the
Speaker 1: ground or any of the stuff.
It's also important to understand
that Putin has done this before.
And it's not a guarantee that Putin
necessarily plans to invade or wants to invade,
invade. He is constantly gauging reactions. Putin
is not stupid. Putin is actually a brilliant
Speaker 2: guy in his own way and he's gauging
Speaker 1: reaction,
Speaker 2: is sowing chaos, is creating
Speaker 1: confusion and massing. The troops
Speaker 2: at the border may not
Speaker 1: be a plan to invade.
Speaker 2: I think the key part
Speaker 1: here is there are some people on
the pro-Trump right who are saying by a Trump
Speaker 2: Sorry, Putin would never
Speaker 1: invade. Obviously, that's not true.
Speaker 2: History tells us
that's not true.
Speaker 1: What could be true
is that Putin does not intend to invade
this particular time and is trying to
Speaker 2: see what kind of reaction
Speaker 1: he can get. Last thought on this
one? It'll be interesting to see how Putin reacts
to Biden's warning. In other words, if this is a
trial balloon, what, if anything, will Joe Biden's
warning do to dissuade Putin or not? That's number
one. And then number two, I got a few emails
from people in the audience thinking along the
same lines, which is is it possible that Russia
and China are coordinating on Ukraine and Taiwan,
respectively to do actions at the same time,
Speaker 2: not not working together,
but the timing
Speaker 1: coordinated in order
to really see if and what the U.S. and NATO are
going to do? It's a very interesting speculation.
I don't think at this point we have evidence
that that's actually what's going on.
But like everything else, we're going to watch it
Speaker 2: and it will be very interesting
Speaker 1: to see what I mean. Quite frankly,
this is the first kind of adversarial foreign
policy test for Joe Biden. Major one, anyway
Speaker 2: of his presidency. So we will watch it.
Speaker 1: Always curious to
Speaker 2: know your thoughts.